[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous
bienvenue dans votre recette 8 dans
l'actualité de ce mercredi 7 septembre
le choc et la désolation après le
suicide du jeune pissiaquer Nicolas
l'adolescent était victime de
harcèlement depuis 2022 au sein du lycée
professionnel Adrienne Bolland une
cellule d'écoute et de soutien a été
ouverte au sein de l'établissement
Brigitte Macron et Gabriel Attal le
ministre de l'éducation se sont rendus
sur place ce jeudi
des idées de sortie également dans votre
set 8 à l'approche du week-end Gabriel
Gontier vous a sélectionné quelques bons
plans pour aller voir le match
d'ouverture de la Coupe du monde de
rugby au programme également le festival
des lumières impressionnistes à Chatou
mais aussi un escape game inspiré de
Fort-Boyard à Vélizy et puis l'invité du
7 8 en deuxième partie d'émission on
sera avec le responsable du plus grand
parcours gonflable d'Europe Florian
Fillon pyramide glissade balle volante
les bulky Games font étape ce samedi sur
l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
[Musique]
deux jours après le suicide de Nicolas à
Poissy le drame est encore dans toutes
les têtes ce jeudi matin devant le lycée
professionnel Adrienne Bolland ou
l'adolescent de 15 ans était scolarisé
jusqu'à l'été dernier son meilleur ami
est venu lui rendre hommage en déposant
un mot sur les grilles de
l'établissement il a appris son décès à
la télévision il s'est fait justement
harceler ici il me l'avait dit et je
suis allé le voir chez lui pour qu'on
puisse jouer comme la vie qui s'était
fait à harceler c'est pas que ça c'est
que le harcèlement s'appelle jusqu'au
suicide mais mais quand même
qu'il le traite comme qui sortent les
insultes qui l'ont sorti quand même ça
se fait pas j'ai marqué merci Nicolas
pour toutes ces années tu étais mon
meilleur ami et tu étais comme un frère
pour moi tu vas nous manquer une cellule
d'écoute et de soutien a été ouverte au
sein de l'établissement où les élèves
sont sous le choc c'est un accident
tragique qui s'est passé dans cet essai
surtout que bah on peut pas s'y attendre
d'un élève qui passe dans le lycée enfin
qui se fait harceler c'est triste enfin
c'est tragique et tout enfin tu te dis
que tu aurais pu agir mais du coup je
savais pas qui c'était forcément pas on
ne sait pas c'est triste et tout
Nicolas s'est donné la mort mardi il a
été retrouvé pendu à son lit dans son
domicile situé dans le quartier de La
Maladrerie deux enquêtes sont ouvertes
l'une judiciaire pour rechercher les
causes de la mort l'autre administrative
menée en interne par l'Éducation
nationale selon les premiers éléments le
garçon scolarisé en 3e prépa métier
avait signalé à son établissement être
victime d'harcèlement des décembre 2022
et nommé les élèves impliqués en mars
2023 les parents ont été reçus par
l'établissement les élèves mis en cause
ont eux aussi été reçu leurs parents ont
été contactés un échange de courriers a
par ailleurs eu lieu courant avril entre
les parents et l'institution scolaire la
famille dénonçant dans ce courrier
l'absence de mesure suffisante prises
face à cette situation de harcèlement
l'établissement indique que le jeune
homme a bénéficié d'un suivi régulier
par la CPE et ce jusqu'à la fin de
l'année scolaire les parents du jeune
homme avaient également déposé une main
courante auprès de la police Nicolas
avait quitté son lycée et effectuait sa
rentrée dans un autre établissement
situé à Paris en début de semaine
Brigitte Macron est le ministre de
l'éducation nationale Gabriel Attal ont
rencontré la famille à la mairie de
Poissy cet après-midi le gouvernement
devrait détailler prochainement son plan
contre le harcèlement scolaire qui
touche en France un élève sur 10
c'est ce mercredi soir aux alentours de
18h qu'un véhicule de police est entré
en collision avec un adolescent qui
circulait en motocross entrés en cours
et morta plutôt dans la soirée après
avoir reçu un signalement les policiers
du secteur ont tenté d'arrêter le motard
le jeune homme de 16 ans auraient alors
pris la fuite poursuivi par les forces
de l'ordre c'est à une intersection au
niveau de la résidence des nouveaux
horizons qu'il percutent un autre
véhicule de police présent par hasard
sur les lieux rapidement alerté par le
bruit des témoins ont filmé la scène
on a entendu le bruit de d'une collision
centre de Ré donc je suis allée voir sur
par la fenêtre et j'ai vu du coup la
voiture la moto pardon qui était qui
était renversé avec plusieurs voitures
de police autour les policiers qui
étaient sur place on fait un massage
cardiaque et j'ai appelé les pompiers du
coup
faut savoir s'ils étaient au courant
parce qu'au bout de 15-20 minutes ils
étaient toujours pas sur place ils sont
arrivés 5 minutes après réanimer sur
place il est ensuite transporté à
l'hôpital Beaujon de Clichy dans les
Hauts-de-Seine en état de mort cérébrale
ce jeudi matin l'émotion était encore
vive pour cette mère de famille
habitante de ce quartier d'ordinaire
calme quand j'ai entendu les alors je
sais pas si c'est sa mère qui hurlait ou
sa sœur mais en tout cas moi ça me
déchire le coeur bien évidemment
contacter la villa pour le moment pas
souhaité s'exprimer les deux policiers
impliqués ont été placés en garde à vue
jusque dans l'après-midi interrogé par
l'IGPN qui s'est saisi de la faire une
unité spécialisée dans les violences
urbaines devraient être déployées à
Élancourt et Maurepas pour éviter des
débordements
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ce projet s'inscrit dans une
volonté de l'ensemble des douze communes
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de
dynamiser l'accueil des Jeux Olympiques
sur le territoire pour célébrer ce
moment pour qu'il soit bénéfice de toute
la population l'objectif c'est
d'impliquer notre population et nous
avons souhaité le faire avec les 12
communes à travers le tissu associatif
de 50 ans en Yvelines celui du monde
sportif mais également celui du monde
culturel par exemple bref toutes les
associations du territoire et des douces
communes qui voudront célébrer les jeux
et les faire en sorte que la population
s'implique au maximum pour l'accueil des
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024
alors on va sur le site tout simplement
de 50 ans Yvelines et on va sur le
portail des associations pourra retirer
son dossier on le remplit on dépose sa
candidature nous nous courons du mois de
novembre alors si on a jusqu'au 3
octobre pour remplir ce dossier courant
du mois de novembre nous réunissons un
comité dans lequel l'ensemble des
communes sont représentées les
spécialistes du monde associatif de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines également et
nous choisirons sur dossier les projets
qui nous sembleront les plus en
adéquation avec la queue des Jeux
Olympiques et surtout le fait de
célébrer ces jeux à travers notre plus
belle Sion et au bénéfice de notre
population
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors évidemment tout au long de l'année
2024 bien évidemment avant les Jeux et
juste avant les Jeux mais depuis le 1er
janvier le but c'est vraiment de faire
en sorte que la population s'approprie
ces jeux et participe à ce moment de
festivités et ça peut être tout à fait
des activités diverses n'est pas
forcément des activités sportives bien
sûr ce seront des activités sportives
mais encore une fois ça peut être des
activités culturelles ce peut-être
d'autres types d'activités qui vont
faire en sorte que chacun ressente le
moment magnifique que vont être les Jeux
Olympiques à 50 ans en Yvelines
[Applaudissements]
dans le reste de l'actualité le Medef
Yvelines inauguré hier soir ces nouveaux
locaux à Montigny-le-Bretonneux près
d'une centaine de chefs d'entreprises
étaient présents sur place pour
découvrir ce lieu auparavant implanté à
Versailles Grand open space salle de
réunion et salon pour recevoir les
adhérents ces bureaux de 155 mètres
carrés ont été choisis pour avoir
davantage d'espace et être au cœur de
l'activité économique 50e
un événement solidaire ce mercredi 7
septembre l'association Lyon club Vélizy
Phénix organisé une collecte de
fournitures scolaires dans le centre
Westfield Vélizy 2 objectifs aider les
familles en difficulté à s'équiper pour
la rentrée les dons seront ensuite
reversés à des écoles ukrainiennes ou
sénégalaises en France les récoltes
seront notamment distribuées au resto du
coeur pour épauler les familles
yvelinoise dans le besoin nous avons
besoin d'un peu près tout ce qui se fait
en fournitures scolaires de du
taille-crayon
jusqu'au cartable en passant par les
cahiers les gommes les stylos les
feutres les ardoises Vileda recharger
son smartphone en pédalant c'est le
concept original proposé depuis quelques
jours à Manille et hameaux sur la plaine
de Chevincourt de bandes de recharge
permettent aux utilisateurs d'éviter la
panne de batterie à la seule force des
jambes grâce à une application gratuite
il est possible de voir la charge en
temps réel de quoi motiver certains à se
remettre au sport
[Musique]
demain matin le soleil sera toujours au
rendez-vous dans les Yvelines côté
température le thermomètre va vite
monter il fera 23 degrés à Versailles 22
à Rambouillet et 21 à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Houdan demain après-midi quelques nuages
vont faire leur apparition du côté de
Houdan et Mantes-la-Jolie au niveau des
températures il fera 32 degrés à Houdan
et Rambouillet et 31 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles pensez à
bien vous hydrater à partir de midi les
Yvelines passent en vigilance orange
canicule c'est l'heure à présent de
votre 7 8 invité
[Musique]
si comme moi vous avez aussi vu passer
l'information sur les réseaux sociaux
vous avez sans doute été intrigués je
vous parle des bulles qui Games il
s'agit du plus grand parcours gonflable
d'Europe et il sera de passage dans les
Yvelines ce samedi 9 septembre sur l'île
de loisirs de 50 ans en Yvelines pour en
parler avec nous Florian Fillon bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes le responsable
des bulles qui Games première question
Florian il y a combien d'obstacles sur
ce plus grand parcours gonflable
d'Europe alors là nous sommes sur un
parcours qui fait 5 km et nous avons sur
ce parcours 12 structures gonflables
géantes et donc c'est quoi ces obstacles
ces structures gonflables c'est parfait
parce qu'on est sur une des structures
notamment qui s'appelle No gravity donc
là vous voyez c'est un obstacle que l'on
doit franchir on doit parcourir ces
différents boudins pour sortir de cet
obstacle donc les participants ont le
choix quand ils franchissent l'obstacle
ils peuvent soit rebondir sur les
trampolines qui sont entre chaque boudin
ou alors faire le choix de monter sur le
boudins et de sauter de boudin au boudin
qui est la solution on va dire un petit
peu plus difficile et il y a quoi
d'autre comme obstacles sur ce parcours
l'avantage de ce parcours c'est qu'on a
vraiment des substacles qui sont
vraiment très variés donc nous avons des
obstacles avec des bras motorisés donc
là on fait un intervenir un moteur qui
va pouvoir faire tourner des bras
tourner des boules mettre en difficulté
un petit peu plus les participants et
puis nous avons aussi des obstacles avec
de l'eau donc notamment un obstacle où
les gens descendent une une glissade
avec une bouée qui leur sert de support
et arrive dans une piscine donc parfait
pour ces cette période caniculaire
puisqu'il fait chaud exactement et alors
est-ce qu'il faut être sportif il faut
est-ce qu'il faut avoir un niveau
sportif ou est-ce que c'est accessible à
tout le monde alors c'est justement le
choix qu'on a fait dans l'entreprise en
montant cette ce parcours c'est qu'on a
fait le choix d'avoir des structures
accessibles à tous donc à partir de 16
ans jusqu'à 77 ans venez vous amuser il
n'y a pas besoin de condition physique
pas besoin de préparation physique on
est vraiment là sur une la possibilité
pour tous alors c'est un concept qui
date depuis plusieurs années est-ce que
vous savez d'où est venu l'idée de créer
le plus grand parcours gonflable
d'Europe alors les deux cofondateurs de
la société sont partis un petit peu à
l'époque où les courses d'obstacles
étaient vraiment à la mode sont partis
un peu dans différents pays et notamment
en Australie où ils ont repéré ce genre
d'événements qui avaient lieu et qui
rassemblée vraiment beaucoup de monde
avec un esprit très festif et ici sont
retrouvés dans ces valeurs là et donc
tout simplement ils ont voulu en mettant
leurs pattes apporter ce concept ici en
Belgique tout d'abord puis en France
donc c'est comme ça que l'histoire a
débuté et donc en France vous tournez un
petit peu il y a plusieurs dates qui
sont proposées exactement cette année là
sur 203 nous avions 11 dates en France
la France est un marché très intéressant
mais il faut savoir aussi qu'on est
présent au Luxembourg en Belgique en
Espagne en Italie et en Suisse donc
l'expansion continue et donc ce samedi 9
septembre vous attendez combien de
personnes environ alors on attend 6000
personnes ce samedi sur la base de
loisirs de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
comme on dit dans le métier c'est à dire
qu'on a réussi à vendre tout nos billets
à l'avance donc on est vraiment très
très fiers d'autant plus que c'est la
deuxième date que l'on fait dans la
région parisienne cette année on en
avait fait une sur la base de loisirs de
vert Torcy et donc là de pouvoir être
ici en septembre et de nouveaux faire
sold out pour nous c'est génial donc là
si je comprends bien il reste plus de
place malheureusement par contre il
reste de la place pour tous les
accompagnateurs et les gens il faut
savoir qu'on est aussi un événement qui
est ouvert à tous ça c'est très
important parce que nous avons un
village avec de l'animation DJ bar food
truck animation gratuite comme ça les
gens peuvent vraiment venir en profiter
entre amis en famille avec une belle
journée comme ça on a des zones d'ombre
on a tout ce qu'il faut pour ravir tout
le monde il y a des animations avant et
après la course alors vous utilisez le
terme course mais il n'y a pas de
classement c'est c'est vraiment pour
s'amuser en fait c'est pour s'amuser on
aime bien utiliser le mot course parce
que ça reste certaines personnes quand
même un challenge de devoir gravir
certains obstacles de devoir affronter
aussi certains certaines choses que nous
rajoutons on a quand même le plus la
plus grande glissade de l'Europe qui
fait 13 mètres de haut il faut quand
même accéder en haut on y arrive par le
biais d'une corde donc il y a quand même
un petit effort physique sur certains
obstacles c'est très léger mais pour
certaines personnes ça représente quand
même un challenge donc on aime bien
garder ce génie ce terme générique on va
dire course si on a un peu le vertige on
c'est faisable non non franchement il y
a pas il y a pas de quoi avoir peur
là-haut nous avons les bénévoles et le
staff qui est présent pour rassurer pour
indiquer toutes les mesures de sécurité
donc non aucun problème et alors en
moyenne on termine en combien de temps
ce parcours les gens en moyenne mettent
entre 1h15 j'ai envie de dire parce que
il faut savoir que 95% des gens vont le
faire en marchant ils vont partir à fond
ils vont faire la première structure et
après ils vont se sentir assez essoufflé
et ils vont se dire allez on va quand
même profiter et donc du coup les gens
mettent plutôt une heure donc vous
l'avez testé je suppose ce parcours d'un
témoin je le connais par coeur merci
beaucoup Florian Fillon d'avoir répondu
à nos questions c'est la fin de ce 7 8
invité je vous souhaite une belle soirée
sur TV 78 merci pour votre fidélité
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]